hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hippie's great foley's great
great
extravaganza went off without a goddamn
hitch it's the last episode before the
big break guys
positive vibes heart energy here we go
foley on you buddy hey everybody out
there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage
it is so show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find if they grew
up classy or if they're
absolute trash i'm your host holy coming
at you on a beautiful day here
aunt toody's basement down here all
cleaned up from the holidays
ready for 2021 baby here we [ __ ] go
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table so you know
what that means kids it's a family
episode
a fan question patreon question
baby just the family we read your
questions on the air
and we have a [ __ ] good time these
are some of my favorite apps baby
always our favorite apps family time
love the family
ladies and gentlemen the
auntie to my uncle all right
the mrs griswold to my clark the tom
to my jerry kippy
kevin james ryan hey pal hey gang happy
to be here thanks so much for tuning in
also someone brought up and i forgot you
haven't been doing ass making a kippy
recently we got to move some merch
you got to remind them you have to fall
back in love i know i don't think he's
he's
he's been sour on me but he's been sour
it happens with the big man he's very
temperamental
last forever we both know hearts can
change he holds it together for an hour
candle in the cold december he holds it
together for an hour while we're on air
but
read some private text messages this guy
sour's quick
um guys thanks so much for tuning in
uh as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe when i do please full
videos
do us a solid right now go do it pause
the podcast make it happen
full video available on youtube uh and
also patreon.com
are you garbage you can sign up you can
really help support the show you can get
bonus content bonus episodes videos
we're doing uh foley's head
head creator of content over there on
patreon he's cranking out the videos oh
yeah we're doing tubby time with kippy
look out we're doing live streams with
you guys where you get to ask us
questions we ask you questions good
times
we did it last week it was a [ __ ]
shot it was hot i'm not lying you
[ __ ] know me
look at my face it was hot get involved
with that baby
yeah yeah we did do that live stream
three weeks ago well whatever you know
what i mean
uh we're living in podcast universe here
uh it's actually
it's march 13th i'm actually skinny by
the time you see this
it takes the light from the planet i'm
from that far away guys thanks so much
uh it's been a bananas year this is
coming out on uh new year's eve it's
been a bananas year for us thank you so
much for all the [ __ ] support
he's dropping new year's eve he's
dropping the 31st baby thank you
so [ __ ] much this has been a [ __ ]
life-changing year for us we really
appreciate it the support from all you
guys has been
[ __ ] awesome we're so grateful thank
you so much
but this is show business it's what have
you done with me lately let's up
everything up in 2021. tell a friend
join a patreon get a hoodie do
something that's right yeah it's good
stuff how about a nice shout out to our
old pal
toby mcmullen t the t-bone
that you've all come to know and love
hey what's up
psyched to be here what a crazy
christmas we had huh that was nuts toby
really plays it cool with the timelines
i watch don't get [ __ ] head don't
shoot a cop with this guy don't tell me
who won the world series all right
i watched kippy's brain be like
[Laughter]
good times we love you guys thank you so
much we appreciate everything you guys
are doing for us
as we say go to podcastmarch.com pick
yourself up a little [ __ ] uh
ayg memorabilia you know what i mean a
little bit of merch a little bit of swag
yeah and some of you guys nice stuff
nice hoodies nice tears
you guys have been asking we kind of
jumped the gun on the real release of
the
card game that should be out in 20. if
you're hearing this we are in bankruptcy
we hit a we hit a snag with production
apparently they wanted to be paid for
this thing our european investors
are holding us hostage yeah uh should be
out very soon so stay tuned for that
yeah the card game's coming it's all
we're just getting warmed up this is a
three-man team baby we're doing it we're
fighting we're fighting and moving stick
and move you know what i mean
now you bozo let's talk a little
business sure all right where'd you get
that t-shirt first of all this is from
kona surf shop in wildwood new jersey
shout out to [ __ ] wildwood new jersey
that's where i've wrapped ever been on a
surfboard i have boogie board yeah i've
gone surfing in your mom
every now and then that's what they do
with surfboard they call it it sounded
sexual
i love you didn't hear kippy got
sponsored dude
yeah shout out go to kona out there on
rio in new jersey
tell them [ __ ] toby sent you i always
thought i always thought jersey uh
surfers were um whack
real whack yeah kid's talking about yeah
we're going down atlantic city to surf
like
no you're not going down to get clam
strips like everybody else
shut up no the surfing's decent in
jersey say with new york
new york too i think long island
washington square park
or on an island baby get to the [ __ ]
luau no long island
who's got the street cred surf wise in
foleyville nobody even [ __ ] surf i
[ __ ] body surfed
like the [ __ ] big kahuna that's how
we do it down the shore
yeah that sounds real cool oh you guys
are going you're there's no jealousy in
that you guys are going [ __ ] surfing
that's whack i'd rather body surf any
day of the week than get on a surfboard
i'll be boogie boarding if i'm not
getting bit by a shark i go three feet
out and wait for the little wave
full fully hits the beach a bunch of
scientists coming we gotta get it back
get a tarp spray him with a guy with a
water gun or something we gotta keep him
wet
he was 100 feet tall if he was a foot i
tell you i just go with it
just go with it let me get a sandwich
over here pouring soda on me
can of sardines get me a can of sardines
by the way that [ __ ] triggered my
memory this might be a little while back
but some animal in the facebook group
posted that picture
of mac and cheese and with sardines
what the [ __ ] i know some of you i don't
know if that was a stock picture i don't
know if that was
animals your lunch or breakfast your
dinner some of you in that group
are [ __ ] savages dogs somebody posted
a sambi with uh some fried onions on it
was all white bread with some doritos
looked ideally
yeah looked a little trish if you ask me
yum yum yum yum yum yum
but that's what we're doing today folks
we got a lot of questions um from the
patreon from facebook it's going to be
me
all you guys today it's all about you
folks bobbing and weaving this is a sign
of appreciation for all you guys we
really [ __ ] appreciate all the
support you know
the activity of you guys the facebook
group is bumping patreon's [ __ ]
bumping we want to you know
and you guys have so many [ __ ] good
questions it's like you know some of
these questions i've had on my list to
ask are just waiting for the right guess
and they sneak in with them we should be
paying you yeah we're not but we're not
that's patreon.com
stop the show um hit me
let's see i think we talked about this i
forget you're i know my answer this is
from eric border
water or milk for hot chocolate it's
winter time
holidays great question growing up it
was always water water you did water
with the smiss
mix powder never even thought to use
[ __ ] milk
yeah or would i don't know foley's in
hot milk just that never happened
we kept it ice cold in a cool way does
anybody milk that was always weird to me
like in a pot
did you ever have somebody drink warm
milk before they went to bed
but none of my friends [ __ ] buffalo
bill yeah those things are
weird what are you fr where are you
hanging out the retirement home
imagine going to dude if my one of my
buddies came over for a sleepover and
asked my dad or mom for a glass of warm
milk
not happening hey weirdo your parents
called they'll be here in ten minutes
he asked for a glass of cutty sark and a
black eye probably gonna get that though
oh wouldn't he shout out to a mickel
home
they were big at the house always water
sometimes
two two three packs if i was left to my
own devices and i would eat the
marshmallows like cereal yeah i never
liked the snacks in the house
i always like putting the fresh
marshmallows what the [ __ ]
why don't you like how the freeze-dried
little cause they remind you of having
lucky charms they were great
yeah but the marshmallow the real
marshmallow was a better marshmallow
hands down you can't debate that
okay so why not that that that'll
[ __ ] i don't want to fight on new
year's eve
all right okay whatever you want to do
you want to go see your sister we'll go
see your sister yeah
this is from jeff p on patreon which
what wait a minute
there was a point in my life when i
discovered that you could use milk and
i've been milk
ever since you still making hot
chocolate that frequent we had hot
chocolate a couple nights ago we each
had a cup for
while we were doing the tree or like you
know but i'm saying before that when was
the last time
i don't know a couple days maybe
you act like i'm crazy for asking you
these quests
i don't know last time i tell you what i
drank that [ __ ] chocolate milk that
uh adrian got us at the show
oh yeah shout out to merry made farms
[ __ ] doing it right
you said you weren't gonna have that
well you were uh caught up in what i
call a lie
and that's that's just the way it went
down he he also gave you
mcdonald's sauce packets and said there
was no food order along with it i'll
show you the receipt downstairs
i didn't [ __ ] buy food do you think a
one okay i'll believe i will produce the
paperwork that will clear my name i
bought you a nice present no no i don't
embarrass myself i don't trust the
receipt i want to see a bank statement
because i wouldn't put it past you
to be like two separate orders one just
sauce one with sandwiches
well that's not gonna happen yeah
because you'll see he wasn't
you'll see he was everywhere you'll see
he was at burger king earlier that day
to see a friend
called the whopper
okay let's get back to the show
back to the show um let's see this is
from core shout out to court our gal
love your court do you guys in your own
house obviously use the same
bath towel as other people like the
person you're you know your husband your
wife your gal your
you know do you share a bath towel
a bath towel no she hasn't no i do i
weigh my weight my butt with my bath
towel i dry my butthole
with my bathroom sure did you do that
i'm not walking around here with a wet
butthole yeah i got to drive my butthole
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] question is that
you dry your hair of course
you gotta have a [ __ ] tight b-hole
yeah my girl's not she's not a fan of
that
so she would never use mine i've used my
girls
yeah you could use your girl she can't
use mine no
no no no hers could be a month and a
half old and it still smells fresh
i use mine once and it's like a [ __ ]
pirate ship i am
i am also a bit of a [ __ ] jerk off
though if i need to dry my
something i use hers instead of oh yeah
you know what i mean like if they're
both hanging on the back of the door and
i just wash my hands
i go hurt she has this she doesn't know
what she's catching she's getting a lot
of
a lot of incidental uses wiping them out
sure blowing my nose whatever i need to
do my girl has a uh
toby's never gonna look at me the same
my girl has like a tear a terry it looks
like a terry cloth
jumper skirt where it goes up like above
her boobies
yeah like a like a towel lounger type
thing exactly yeah yeah
it's a towel and it has like um it has
elastic on it to you know keep it on and
like you know that's what she puts on
and then she puts her her hair up in the
towel you're jerking off on it
no but i wait my i've been i've been
wiping my face on that yeah that's yeah
yeah it's like a sundress at that point
100 yeah yeah yeah
i'm an i'm an animal with we were just
talking about i was i'm an animal with
my towel in general like i won't
i very when i'm doing laundry i very
rarely to remember to wash the towels
because they're in the bathroom they're
on the door they're not like where the
rest of the laundry is
and i'm only thinking about a towel when
i turn the shower off is when i'm
thinking about a towel
where do you allow your towel to dry
post shower um
i my why i go over the door because you
get more
surface area if you hang it on the hook
it stays clunched up and it might catch
a smell it stays wet longer
you gotta go over the door to really let
the air get to it what the best thing it
probably is but i think it's so trashy
is when you hang it over the shower
when you fly that's not bad i kind of
like that my girl well there's the mat
over there too to dry the mat out
ah no but conversely though the
over the door can be complete trash if
you just go corner of the door just like
throw it up there yeah
and then it's the worst of both worlds
sure because you don't corner it yeah of
course on the corner no but he's saying
like it's still full
you got to pull it out and make sure the
dirt shuts down yeah you can't you're
doing your business you can't close the
door in my apartment without taking a
[ __ ] towel off
which i was thinking we have a vera i
was thinking about this last night we
have a very loose door policy in my
apartment
what does that mean people are coming
and going doesn't matter whatever
you know yeah i think that's weird if i
i wouldn't if i
went into one of the rooms in my
apartment and shut the door
that would that door would be open to
like what are you doing what are you
doing in here no i'm not saying that i'm
saying bathroom whatever like i just
know if it's like you're [ __ ] with
the door open
if it's no i'll close i'll close the
door
because it's devastating i mean dude i
don't know i'm laying down some [ __ ]
bad stuff in there it's tough come
across it
a time or two i didn't like it it's bad
there is not a casual dump in this room
no
no it's all [ __ ] it's micro dirty
jobs we're [ __ ] doing it there's no
pg-13 situation over here
all rated r ah um not admit it without
parent
which this this is this is a bit of a
sidebar i
uh my wife bought me a massage the other
day we go to this
shout out to may may does massages in
our tent should you listen
i left the business card i don't know if
she [ __ ] shows her free lunch i don't
know if she peruses
but like once a month once every two
months or three months honestly my wife
will be like oh go get a massage you
know here i got
i ordered you a book to massage she gets
acupuncture there so she's like i
ordered you a massage from the gal so i
go okay great
so i go and i've been eating a lot of
spin i've been eating way better so i've
been eating a lot of spinach and spinach
i don't know about you guys but
[ __ ] open the floodgates of wide open
it [ __ ] goes right through me
minutes like so i should eat all in the
[ __ ] toilet it goes quick
i'm not trying to be gross here but so i
thought that's attractive
i'm sorry brad pitt over here
all of a sudden all of a sudden worried
about [ __ ]
poop stories
talk about wiping your ass on your on
your on your girlfriend's dress
and i'm a [ __ ] savage um
so i had a big you know if you've been
eating healthy and that when you're
eating healthy it [ __ ] goes baby
that's like you know natural lubricant
in the [ __ ]
in the in the intestines there no
construction on that highway no
no easy parts sunday afternoon driving
so i'm getting a massage in about 20
minutes into a 60-minute er
i'm all loose and relaxed and i grew
like the [ __ ]
bubbles are like i'm talking you gotta
fart or you gotta [ __ ]
farts i mean for or an hour pass farts
i'm talking water at the gate like
you say hey excuse me i have to go
eventually but this is like a
this is not a conducive place to people
we're gonna hear you [ __ ] you don't have
trickling water meanwhile there's people
like meditating and get an acupuncture
and i'm [ __ ] clogging the toilet
i can't do that but i'm talking like
water at the wall the dam's about to
break
i'm [ __ ] trying to relax meanwhile
i'm sweating she's like you're tense i'm
gonna
suck i hate that feeling but then it'll
subside i can convince myself that'll
you know the water will move elsewhere
you know tidal go out i guess
it will for me oh it did you could pull
it back so then it was about five
minutes left and [ __ ] you know
knocking on the devil's door again
and i'm like i'm gonna take this badge
from me she wrapped it up pretty quick
and i was like i took like [ __ ] a
hundo at her like later that's
[ __ ] around inside good night yeah
ever since i [ __ ] my pants last year i
don't [ __ ] with it
i don't like it it's tough it's tough
man you gotta be right you gotta be on
your toes
i've noticed that i have to get up like
an hour earlier than i would like to
because i need to let things organize
you know what i mean and then there's
usually you know gotta get your affairs
in order
yeah because it doesn't just because you
can wake you if you rush out of the
house too
quick that's no i don't have that
problem oh i'm like i can rush out of
the house be like oh i feel i don't have
to
feel great and then you get halfway to
the subway and you're [ __ ] no i'm
like a
i'm like i'm like a plane that dumps it
in the middle of the air it's like
and it's out and i'm good there's
nothing when i'm done
until joe dirt finds it there's nothing
there is abso it's
bone dry in there i'm [ __ ] clean how
forest fires
oh but yeah it's like it's like it's
like a helicopter dumping its load
i'm scuba diver in there
couple of trout
yeah dude i [ __ ] it's an emergency
shoot there's nothing not coming out
i've never had that problem uh
moving on this is from jeff p which i
have on the page what was that question
about me [ __ ] my pants at a massage
i don't know um
wiping your butt or maybe i think that's
how we got into oh using the
girlfriend's towel
yeah that's how we got into it oh and
then door open door policy this
yeah you know yeah so she's dumping with
the door open no she does it but i'm
just saying like
if sh if she's in the shop every it's
just very
short very open there's no like a peek
if sh
what of her in the shower i don't need a
sneak one
the cameras are running
[Laughter]
i think the ring light gives it away i
got a sign on the front doors as you are
now entering you can
you give up all permission martin
lawrence special
close circuit television baby i got a
deck of monitors in the closet
old man in there an old retired cop
ham and cheese sandwich and a cup of
coffee smoking a burning yeah she's
brushing her teeth
i gotta keep an eye on her
this is from jeff p which i feel is just
a shot at me do you have eczema
i guess that means
you need the lotion okay listen you
sitting here
criticizing my lotion i'm not
criticizing i'm trying to help you no
you go jesus you
you need i'll come you later you look
dry but i'm a boy
i'm moist this is what you do you hold
on
you hold on to your hairline and your
skin you're
dying you are going buddy we're all
dying
act accordingly um i
originally had the insider i had a bout
uh of it on my wee-wee to get a little
why
yeah and i didn't know what to talk
about panic attack
city next stop i didn't know what it was
what were those google searches like oh
man
you know you're looking it was it was
bad
it was so bad that i i couldn't google
it because i'm like i don't want the
answers
yeah so put some ice on it and hope it
goes away tomorrow so
i thought it was like maybe the towel so
i
just just thinking about you looking at
your little pee pee
freaking whoa whoa who said it was
little i was chopping up
i was playing the guitar down just make
it look at least four inches
oh that's what and that's a tough spot
because like what are you gonna bring
your girl into the mix
so i mean you know i don't want to hash
you know so i was like that was the
problem
yeah so right away i go oh it's a
[ __ ]
you know it's a he it was in the summer
it was in august or whatever i'm like oh
it's a heat rash so whatever you know
sweaty
something blah blah blah i hit it with a
cream tough acting tanakh then something
that don't that got it mad to be honest
with you
she was angry that day much like a swarm
of bees and a wiffle ball bat
man the queen was upset
so he started fighting back a little bit
and he came dude
why he's going home it hurt
it was a scene so i switched towels i'm
like maybe it's an old maybe i gotta
switch out the towel clean towel do it
then i'm gonna ain't the towel she's
stepping out on you
that's what i'm talking [ __ ] i'm like
oh this that so then
um i'm hitting it with the hair dryer
cause i'm going if it's completely dry
like the
moist because you know so you got the gi
drip kid so
cut two then i get it on my arm here and
that's uh
someone's like that's eczema and i go so
i start googling eczema on the johnson
that you can live with and that they
sold how long
how long was the gap between it showing
up on your dick
and your homie identifying it on the arm
it seemed like [ __ ] five years dude
it seemed like
long it seemed i don't know i don't know
my elbow's cheating i lived and died a
lot of times in that
in that period of whatever it was
so then i'm like i get whatever cream
it's like hydro
whatever i was using the wrong cream
originally i got the one for eczema and
then like 10 seconds it's gone dude
nice i put it on it burned like a sum of
a [ __ ]
i'm a big fan of all that stuff
cortisone cream [ __ ] knocked it right
out
[ __ ] hasn't been back yeah no you're not
trash if you
have eczema no you got it on your dick
i was [ __ ] my elbow um
i believe that was a shot at you what
that
it might have been i like it yeah i'm
fine with it yeah
um this is from lacey bradley lacy
bradley
on the old at patreon.com
um anyone this is uh
trash anyone get a piercing at home my
dad pierced my ears with an ice cube and
needle
saved 14 bucks your dad yeah
actually it was just one ear i pushed
out for the second one only if your dad
had an ear piercing and still rocked it
or had it when he was younger i guess
he would know about it yeah if he was in
that world if you're a biker or the
in the hills angels or something maybe i
can see it but if your dad's like a
you know a [ __ ] i.t guy and he's
piercing you're here you're trash yeah
that's a [ __ ] half a pizza right
there come on
go to go to [ __ ] you know the
piercing pagoda in the mall
grab a slice of saboros call it a
[ __ ] day yeah go to claire's
yeah somewhere i i didn't have the
piercing for free you buy the earrings
you get the piercing for free
i didn't i didn't toby's in there
getting a dick pierced the declares
the gun ain't big enough it's got a door
handle on it
no i didn't get a piercing but i did i
did have pierced ears uh
shout out i had one of course you did
dude i had i had one going for a while
and i was walking through the mall and i
sat i saw some little tubby kid walking
with one earring and i was like
that's what i [ __ ] look like and then
instead of taking it out my dumb ass
went and got the other one done
i kind of respect that you're a rebel
you're a skater kid you know
i might get my ears pierced i might get
my left ear pierced
is that cool no no it's bad no
but i but i got but not not quite gages
but like a thicker
oh a thicker like a 14 or whatever
i don't know but i couldn't i couldn't
get it in myself
and my mom tried she's like i can't do
it i'm hurting you cut to that night
she's all tuned up on bailey
she's like get in here yeah yeah yeah
bailey
bailey's is trash if you're getting
drunk on just bailey's you are
garbage we're not allowed to have it in
the house anymore so my mom won't put it
down when she pops it's like pringles
bro
what does she have it over ice yeah it's
nice
dude you know what's real nice when i
when i fly uh when i go
to when i used to go to my when we go
home with my girl or whatever we fly
uh german airline lufthansa which is
very nice for some reason they push
heavy the baileys on you
so i'll have a bunch of ipas at the bar
at the airport get all tuned up
get on there order a whiskey or two on
the cuff
whack them down and then they come
around after dinner you want some
bailey's like i'll take a
two tree of them [ __ ] on the rocks
take the edge
right off let me ask you this my flying
experience isn't too
uh keen but and we've always flown coach
i don't think they've you don't say
they've never actually
charged us for drinks there's the menu
oh this is this but then
it's okay the sodas no the booze
they should be charging now we got on
the cuff almost every time we've flown
maybe once or twice it's weird depends
what you're flying and that might be
included
it depends what you're flying yeah air
each airline is different
you ever flown uh you ever flown first
class skippy you ever get the bump i
have i've never been bumped up i've had
somebody pay for my first class ticket
oh we talked about this in the norman
episode
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly my cousin
paid shout out to liam
i have not if you're if you're if you
ever get the bump out there and you're
listening and you want to do something
fun it's a fun game you can play
it's called will they cut me off yeah
that happened
the answer is no you got cut off no we
drank them out of vodka on
the way to miami so it was like a two
and a half hour flight we drank all the
vodka on the plane
i had a i had a whiskey before the plane
took off and then i was pounding
whiskeys
and then i was like wait wait if i if i
keep going whiskey they're gonna cut me
off
so i better switch to wine as we were
landing i was like can i get another red
she was like we're out i was like
white'll do and she's like trying to
like
[ __ ] make sure everyone's get off me
sarah get off me white'll do
i'm an animal i'm the same way once i
get to a certain point it's like you
could give me [ __ ] bleach and i'll
drink like i just need something to keep
the ball in the air you know what i mean
i'm gonna add demons away yeah keep it
coming i don't care
whatever it is i'm doing it um
yeah i one time pierced my buddy shout
out to james i p he was like i want to
pierce my eyebrow and i'm like all right
dude i'll [ __ ] do it we were like 13
or whatever
so he's like i'm like ice it up man you
know i'll let's [ __ ] go
so i got it in with a safety pin like
the big you know the hefty safety pin
jones
and i got it in and under the skin
but then couldn't get it through the
skin so it was just hanging there
and i'm like yeah man i'm out like i
don't have it in me to keep going hey we
got stove top today yeah
bouncing so he finally did it him so he
got it through him see they can't he was
shaking
like he was like hey how's it look man
i'm like yeah i was like smoking a
bernie i was like 13.
like it looks good dude see ya my buddy
got my buddy fell and split his dome
open and had staples in it
and he was like yo i don't want to pay
for them to take them out will you pull
them out for me
they come out easily though
oh really it got stuck i got one of the
same thing halfway out i was like dude
i'm out
i'm out check out you feel like it's
moving in the skin i'm like dude nope
that's it hey man your insurance didn't
go through tough
buddy you got the copay on you
i got my ear pierced in college at my
fraternity house one of my boys did it
living on a prayer
man i would have beat you up in college
if we crossed paths i don't think so i
would have worked
you you would have been the biggest top
bro call mahoney
it wasn't like that at all you probably
had friends named mahoney and
played i played lacrosse in college with
a kid named mahoney of course you did
ryan mahoney
shout out to rye wherever you are big
guy cool kid introduce me
this one goes out to you introduce me to
social distortion
great band oh sorry who do you like the
illinois
i don't know sometimes you really phone
it in and when you mess you give up
he gives up quick
for the listener we're on our second
episode of the day and he's playing
coach [ __ ] over here
if it ain't coming across the plate he
ain't got it
winter rules here let's get this guy a
tea
home run derpy we have to run this out
do we i was told this was a meet and
greet
it's all gimme putts with this guy yeah
that's a give me right
17 feet from the hole that's a gimme
come on not at all
[Laughter]
no we would have been friends now
after we made love no
you i don't think we would have
connected i wasn't an [ __ ] like that
i wasn't running around my mouth dude
relax
calm down you act like i'm like we're
gonna come oh yeah
you remember i'm saying you were so
cool jockey that i don't i would have
been like that i don't like that guy
you just weren't the same people then
that's what i'm saying as much
reverence as you hold for your high
school and college i was also
hold on i was also okay you know finish
yours finish your point i'm sorry i got
it
no you i was also eating what you were
gonna say that you're i'm also eating
what'd you say
there's something i didn't say eaten i
said i was also emo like i was in the
poetry and i listen
well then i definitely gonna shove you
in a locker what are you talking about
i love how he thinks he's gonna get me
nah i was writing poetry i wasn't
what you were thinking i wasn't a
typical jock i'm just saying the way
with the reverence you hold now
to those days yeah had a good time um
yeah yeah of course to each their own
you know i just don't think we would
have seen eye to eye
you would have been [ __ ] playing the
acoustic guitar at a party or something
i would have been like yo
get a load of this [ __ ] douche i'm
out this guy's a freddie deeb over here
see you later
simply dusty yeah [ __ ] messed up same
smile
you're like oh is this tuned down oh
that's what it is somebody tuned it down
saying i don't have my pick on me
i've done that and i stunk i'll play it
in public i gotta
yeah oh man yeah it wasn't until i got
up here where i was able to actually
play out in public
but one time man we invited everybody to
come see us play
and uh it was at kenny's castaways in
the west village
and we left all of our stuff on stage
and we went to get something to eat you
know before the show
and some other band went up on stage and
twisted all of our i love how you think
somebody had an alfre you didn't just
stink
some bands some other cover bands
sabotaged us
and detuned tuned me down a half a step
they did i was all over the place
nothing was in tune with each other and
it was all interesting yeah you guys
stunk what are you talking about
i love this band plays their first show
and somebody sabotaged you
hey do you hear foley and the fatsos are
coming down we got to get them
[Laughter]
my boss was there oh man they were all
so embarrassed
uh i mean i really i mean we've had you
know i've had bad shows where people
come out and you get [ __ ]
you know comedy's one thing this was
music this was like this kid stinks
where was it originals or lovers
originals a couple of covers couple of
projects just to keep them in you know
what i mean got to keep them in games
give them the high heats
now a bunch of pearl jam covers and
smashing pumpkins covers
bad despite all my rage i'm still just
fat in a cage all right guys we're
having fun
we're having a good time here yeah um
all right this is from uh
be low shout out to be low on the old ad
patreon below money
um this is a big one what's your phone
charger game like
this isn't it he says this is an
excellent guar excellent garbage
indicator
i didn't grow up trashy but having three
kids has made me a little frugal
i'm the guy bending the cord wrapping
the cord around shoving it up your
[ __ ] whatever
before i replace them it yeah it goes on
it goes on too long
way too long it goes on way too long i
think in my head i feel like i think
they're a million dollars you know what
i mean when you're like oh it's like 20
bucks my cat choose them she chews the
end of them
so mine will do the thing where it's
charging it's not charging it's charging
each time i know
charging it's not charging and then you
got you got like a little makeshift
shim underneath i i have to do that now
but it's not the charger it's the phone
inputs all [ __ ] up
so i gotta like prop it up on the cool
you know you gotta like i gotta have
some
i can have some pressure from the bottom
to keep the [ __ ] you know
the connector going been been there yeah
it's trash
real trout when it charges like 20 bucks
everybody should have new chargers oh
and
also don't skimp on the [ __ ] buy a
real one dude
i know the 7 11 john's that oh you've
infected me with your
[ __ ] slang john's oh
[ __ ] i don't even realize that yeah just
i can't go down to a [ __ ] old town
what's this [ __ ]
tell them calling somebody agent they're
gonna think i'm a [ __ ] president i
gotta do to mike at murphy's next week
don't throw me out of the building over
there you know now get a good one that's
all i'm saying
no for sure like invasion of the body
snatchers
um all right this is uh this is a super
[ __ ] this i mean this is trash we've
touched it a
couple of times here and there this is
hit me richard gere's
gerbil i don't think that's his
government name
it was a rumor for a long time yeah
durable up his ass
that was just everybody that was
everybody being jealous of how
good-looking richard
you've never heard that girls today
still think richard gere's good looking
no i'm just laughing at fully explaining
this guy's joke name
sure what you have to do is you have to
take the you have to declaw the gerbil
first though otherwise it hurts too much
we'll scratch the [ __ ] out of you gotta
rip his little teeth out too
yeah he'll probably start biting oh man
i had a gerbil shot at the peanut in
midnight
my mom let him go tonight was a dirty
one
for night time um this is a uh
tangent she let them go how long do you
think those gerbils last in your
backyard
they ran back in the house they're not
stupid and we found them in the garage
my mom's my mom said they died and she
buried them when we were away on
vacation with my
dad yeah and then my brother came and
he's like peanuts in the garage
my mom's like [ __ ] goddamn people
thought we had a deal
yeah you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] 20 grand
disappear you leave town tonight
um i was one night i was we were in
college and we were i was going out to
uh the bar shout out to tiki bob's that
was big back in the day in philly were
you in philly for tiki bob's days
i didn't really go to bars i'll be
honest with you it's over there by
mcfadden's nah he never did it
never did it i didn't even like the bars
in college i'm more of a house party guy
more of an emo guy it's more like a
coffee place the poetry open mic yeah
it's it's way harder to steal people's
beers at the bar
more of a house party guy yeah fully
he's like he's like i'm more of a
houseboarding guy it's way harder to
steal
their fraternity at fraternity parties
every weekend
with the put to juice or whatever well
college is different from saying in your
philly days you aren't in college
nah i never really went to bars i didn't
before accommodating
a pharmacy kind of guy hey kitty can you
remind me to edit myself out of this
episode
control alt delete hey can somebody
force quit t-bone
this kid needs a reboot this guy's
jamming on my browser
somebody needs an update over there
um i was going out to the bars getting
ready and i was a big fan of scrubs the
tv show and on one of the
episodes of scrubs uh a guy had a light
bulb
stuck up his ass right and the whole
thing of scrubs was how they're gonna
get the light it was
intact and they said but if you pull it
the pressure whatever like it'll crack
so the whole idea was how you're gonna
get the light bulb out of this out of
this guy's ass that was like the whole
joke whatever
and the idea that what they did i don't
know if it works in real life but
they're going to the lamp
that's what somebody said they call the
janitor in to be like i can put a lamp
in there and screw it out which is
really funny by the way the janitor in
scrubs was hilarious fantastic
um he has my favorite line ever written
in a sitcom
uh they got jd zack braff gotta gotta
look at his penis
and he goes hey man i saw your penis uh
i saw a tumor let me take a look like he
really did he's like let me take a look
at the tumor
and then they cut to zac bradley they
got the janitors pulling his pants up
and zach perhaps taking off a rubber
gloves he goes good news is it's benign
he goes benign but nine and a half
fantastic writing ah but nine but
so the whole episode of the whole
premise of this episode is they were
trying to get the light bulb out so they
the idea was
the strongest part is the top right
because that's like the cone i don't
know whatever
so you put a balloon up there blow it up
and then push down from the top
it's not going to break so cut to an
hour later i'm at the bar and there was
this douche this like
[ __ ] outside douche that was in our
circle every now and then he was like
trying to hit on this girl that was like
way out of his league and he's like
yeah i'm a pre-med or i'm in med school
whatever
and he told he goes yeah somebody came
in
last week with a light bulb he stole
from scrubs he goes
and i'm i'm ordering a drink i'm like
this cannot be happening that's some
scrubs and scrubs
100 called them out i was like dude get
out of here
what do you do i'm like that's a [ __ ]
scrubs episode i just watched it
episode 232 yeah he was like no i swear
that happened i'm like you
you're gonna tell me you aren't putting
on your polo tonight and we're watching
scrubs and we're like i'm gonna use this
at the bar
jeez for sure kimi's like i got a tumor
i want to show you
benign but nine millimeters and a half
okay um this is from richard gears
gerbil
uh do you or any anyone in your family
compete in any non-athletic sport
leagues such as darts
bowling cornhole horseshoes basically
any sport where someone can
trash trash trash trash yeah where you
can excel being blackout drunk
uh darts were big in my um extended
family for a while
lawn darts no not lawn darts um woody by
big do you mean like
what go places to play or play at home
my uncle red
played in in some serious uncle red yeah
uncle edge
edge school red orange edward was his
name he had red hair they
called him uncle red but also had the
nickname uncle edge it would have been
scarier if he didn't have red hair [ __ ]
they call you red old man
you don't want to know but he was like a
serious star player
and this isn't this is an upstate
pennsylvania so in the in the 80s and
90s yeah they were so he was a pretty
big deal
there was some serious dart leagues
going on
cornhole um think is garbage like just
unbelievable garbage the name of it is
garbage
corn just the whole thing the only
ladder ball
nut ball but i play with your mom
hi who tetherball uh bad bad mittens
really trash too
um horseshoes is the only gentleman's
game to be honest with you
go out you pitch some horseshoes that's
not that gentlemany but
you know it's the most socially
acceptable yeah that other shit's
[ __ ] i got a buddy i like darts too
though
i got a buddy in a dart league shout out
to pat and he's like yeah you know steve
when my dart league's coming over i'm
like i'm out
he's got a jersey on you like dude hit
the [ __ ] bricks
you know dark looks like it looks like a
soccer goalie like what are you doing in
that thing
um that's trashy i make fun of my buddy
who's in an intramural basketball league
is your age that's like a men's league
though at that point that's getting out
of the house staying fit i get that i
feel
then they go to have they go to like pj
willingham's they have beards and wings
afterwards yeah that's big
i got i got i got buddies that play like
hockey and men's league and they just
get all like [ __ ] up afterwards but
that you know
hey they each their own to each their
own clean living out there
i get drunk on my own terms i don't have
to pay league dues man
i do throw forks at the wall i do throw
plates at the wall
i fight with him when i fight with my
wife
hit the window it's 10 points
ah that's too too good um
let's see here let's get that let's go
over to the old facebook page
that's something from here you know what
i mean shout out to the facebook page
this is a big one which i just did the
other day this is from
iver fondon iver shout out to ivor in
the facebook group
have you ever intentionally waited for
the barista to make eye contact with you
before you drop your tip in the jar
like a stanza 100 with the calzone 100
well that's the only time i'll do it i
want an acknowledgement i
i want to thank you thank you i'll even
be like i hear you like i'll
i'll make sure you know i'm tipping you
sure and if you sniff me
with a uh thank you or something i'll go
back in and get it
no you don't yeah i take a little
handling fee too take a couple extra
nickels out of there 75 cents for this
cigarette
get a lucy um i just did it the other
night getting uh
[ __ ] slices right do you really take
the money back no
but i'm devastated i i've never been in
a
position
i don't
which makes you not a good person
because you want them to know you're a
good person well yeah i mean i want to
you know
know that i know how to take care of my
boys at the pizza at my pizzeria place
well you haven't been there in a while
right i've not been there in a while
i do not always pop in for christmas say
what's up to the gang
get a you know a famous christmas
pepperoni pie
it's the holidays okay on a seamless
grubhub
style order where you have the option
for like the 10
20 custom number if you're custom
tipping you're a [ __ ]
scumbag what if you're going custom up
though i think people oh
people i know people that go custom up
people with a little bit of cage you can
you can go cuss them up
with seamless you can do 10 15 20.
that's it
you can't do 10. yes you can there's no
shame in a 10 tip on seamless i don't
think
yeah i don't think i think there
i is go 15 but i'm saying it's better
than a dollar or two dollars
which is what you're going to get if you
i think toby's a custom job yeah
looks like i'm not going to lie i've
done some custom jobs in my house
come on man it's like 88 cents more it
is
the only the only reason is because
you're comparing it to the other numbers
you're going
350 or 278. oh my god it's [ __ ] a
nickel here nickel there you know
yeah that's bad i'm not i'm not proud of
it t-bone no customs take the custom
button off come on man
it's been a long time you're
representing the podcast now they put
two and two together they really oh my
god this is diva
i'm off camera not anymore
um all right this is uh uh this is from
nikki p p p p p p p
p nikki uh this is on patreon uh this is
a big one we kind of touched on before
when you do laundry how long will you to
take your clothes out of the dryer and
fold them
i have my own washer and dryer which
don't get me wrong it's clean living but
i'll just leave them in there
we're just taking them out over the next
week we've discussed this yeah the
dryer's fine you've even been there all
week
you can operate i operate out of it
operate out of the dryer you can fluff
up every morning
yeah with whatever's left in there do
whatever you want live your life throw a
[ __ ] dryer sheet in there
splash a little cold water in there to
crisp it up but you can't leave anything
in the [ __ ] washing machine
and that's just the way it goes i won't
even go like even if i go
even if i forget by like a few hours and
then watch it again just throw it again
it's in there just
[ __ ] run it that's a good litmus test
for how you're doing in life if you've
got a fresh stack of dryer sheets on top
ready to go
oh yeah dryer sheets are always a
purchase you forget to buy
yeah and but then but then when you can
when you can get them no hesitation no
second thought that's a great feeling
yeah
i was just thinking when i was paying i
just don't have to ever think about
money like just
stop thinking about like the date like
ah this or that you know what i mean i'm
like trying to get in a position where
i'm like i got 100 bucks in my bank
account this is great you know what i
mean
one day guys get yourself some dryer
sheets it's patreon.com
it's a real attainable dream a hundred
dollars in the bank account
i'll get you there one day stick with
old uncle hank
yeah uh this is from george g
i'm not gonna try to butcher your last
name georgie um in patreon have you ever
have you or a fember ever refused to get
rid of a piece of furniture or appliance
and just let it sit idly by in the house
for way too
long years uh such as having an old
broken tv
table laying around my parents had an
old china cabinet filled with booze and
files
in quotations jesus um we were lucky we
had a big basement
right we had a big basement on my mom's
house so that's where just like
because where the poor mentality say
mental behind a fridge you don't throw
out a perfectly good table or something
just recently
she started clearing house but if we got
a
new table in the 90s or a couch in the
nine i went down the basement and you
just
put it against the wall like there was
no interior decorator down there it's
just whatever the [ __ ] is old you know
yeah my mom uh she was she's all about
the purge she would throw everything out
all the time if she could
really yeah she keeps it moving i mean
obviously things that we were using that
are like family heirlooms or whatever
you want to say
no but she'll she'll throw a [ __ ]
coffee table out in the front yard with
a [ __ ]
uh a piece of loose leaf that says free
on it and a heartbeat
yeah that's true drag that out yeah you
ever pick anything up out there yeah
well
i've talked about this going [ __ ]
trash picking with my stepdad on sunday
nights was like
what i wanted to do i was like let's
[ __ ] go dude
steal a bike that may or may not be in
the trash maybe in the front yard maybe
in the trash
you know i just got a good question you
ever pick anything up off the craigslist
free section uh i've looked a lot
i've i continue to look you always think
you can find a gym i'm trash at heart so
like if i can find something
i remember my there was a ball remember
two street annies or something there's a
bar or call it's
susie's bar or something in philly it
closed and they were getting rid of all
of their
out of the 60s they were getting rid of
all of their bar wear so my buddy went
and picked up a bunch of [ __ ]
shot glasses they were not used they
were like uh you know they had ordered a
bunch
that's cool yeah so like but then we had
like 500 shot classes at my buddy's
college house so then like you just
start smashing them you know what i mean
like
i mean what are a bunch of drunk guys on
[ __ ] they're drinking they're playing
quarters with vodka
you know you're just [ __ ] smashing
glasses all over the place
one of those one of the smartest
scummiest things i ever did was i posted
in the craigslist free section and
who wants this dick was uh
free hog come on down to roseman
it was uh order me a pizza
like craigslist free i want something
free order me a pizza
two two separate peoples sent me some
[ __ ] dominoes and they're gonna get a
custom tip because i ain't tipping them
jesus that's garbage
man what is wrong with you this guy
stinks
no you don't understand how far i have
come dude i am
i am a new man i am [ __ ] well you
seem like trash
on top of the world now i'm great dude
now we're tipping 20 on the delivery
we got dryer sheets up top paying for
all the pizzas
it's a new life at the mcmullen
household
toby's doing very well he's paying for
his own pizzas yeah
um all right this is
this is this one blew my mind more than
trash
this is from brandon bolton in the
facebook group ever throw your cereal
out in the toilet there was too much
cereal
for the sink and too much milk for the
trash which i'd i've never
not finished something in a bowl of
cereal i'm drinking the milk
i'm i'm going till one of them's out
and then i drink you know it's going uh
have you ever not finished a bowl of
cereal yeah yeah i dispose of it
i've never not finished the first bowl
of cereal
but the third or fourth i might not be
able to get through dude the third bowl
of [ __ ] special k
dude when [ __ ] quarantine hit i went
and got dude they must have dropped off
a pallet of special k at my house
good night cause you're crushing it
[ __ ] you're at like 15 000 cars by
breakfast
special case all right i'm really
showing my ass but i lived in an
apartment
with no kitchen and no heat and i would
dispose of all my [ __ ] in the toilet and
wash my
wash my dishes in the tub oh my god
wow we didn't have come a long way
are you garbage gmail.com if you want to
be a producer this guy is strange
i can't trust him around his own camera
there's no kitchen sink in here
so where are you washing your dishes now
what nothing right never mind see have
another piece of that candy you got to
boost up
i'm good cut that out though
sure you trim that out i was saying he's
come a long way but there's no
sink in here like he hasn't come that
far it's an intellectual joke all right
[ __ ] call me out
i say something you laugh pinhead let's
go next question
what do you got uh
i've thought about this a lot i've never
done it this is from alex
verhyler uh have you ever made a dirt
bike street legal to use it as
transportation
i wouldn't even i thought you just put a
uh license plate on it
you gotta have turn signals and stuff
light dirt bikes don't have that
why you know what you don't need a
leftover i grew up in the woods i'm
sorry
you gotta wait for the deer to cross
what do you mean i had a [ __ ] bicycle
like a gentleman
um uh i always thought like as a [ __ ]
little dirtbag kid i really i was always
wanted a quad and a dirt bike like i
said i had the mini bike i wanted well
in the 80s and 90s movies they were just
driving them on the street like it was
nothing yeah they were ninjas and stuff
they don't care it's lawless
[ __ ] worried about worried about the
dmv they gotta [ __ ]
they gotta get down to the fight well
that's why that's why you wanted them
well i wanted them if there was ever
traffic i could be like bam hey man just
like head into the woods and
get to work like in my brain i was
working somewhere where i could like
pull up on a dirt bike
this is something that i just thought of
that i haven't thought of in probably
30 years but fisher price before i got
like star wars and gi joes
i had fisher price toys they would have
like a boating adventure would be like a
little boat and like a scuba diver and
like a little shark
or whatever one was this stunt man that
rode this dirt bike
and he was dude he hung on the handles
perfectly yeah i know him do you know
what i'm talking about that fisher-price
dirt bike guy yeah
uh i thought it was like this big or so
yeah yeah yeah i love that dude
no no he was like the size of a gi joe
on a little on a little dirt bike well
maybe not then
um that maybe one ever six feet tall
here's the foot i tell you
he was talking about some guy that was
nailing your mom you mean frank
i love that guy let me look at his dirt
bike let me ask you that have you ever
seen your mom on the back of a
motorcycle
no i wouldn't respect her
i'd go live with my dad if that was the
case yeah if my mom pulled up on a
i would [ __ ] and smack the [ __ ]
get in the house you well i don't think
she was that far away in the 90s
my step oh yeah she could have my
stepdad
she had the big hair she was smoking
some more blight sneaking him out i saw
him if she would have met a record
producer or something like that well
my stuff you would have he's a big motor
guy
right like he's big into boats wave
runners he had race car he was a race
car driver at one point like he's like
uh
he just wasn't into bikes but if he was
into bikes she'd be on the you know
saddle bag susie back there
she would be on a bike and i would have
to go live with my dad whale tail
sticking out
i don't like the way you said that and
then looked at me
um my mom wore leather pants one time i
almost freaked out i'm listening keep
going
how old was she oh she's 66. i it was my
it was my cousin joe's wedding she tried
to wear them to the brush what
just listen listen what is she in poison
who the [ __ ] wears leather pants to a
brunch of a wedding the next day that's
what i'm saying puss up
sugar she's dumping a pitch of water on
her chest
patty what are you doing
[Laughter]
it looked like a pair of boots all the
way up i leather pants were like big at
the time
and it was the winter and they were like
thick leather pants and
uh we woke up the next morning she put
them on to go to the brunch
and i refused to go to the brunch i
freaked the [ __ ] out
i was like 13. i was like you're not
[ __ ] walking around there like that
shaking your tail feather yeah it's like
i was born in 58 or something
i don't know what came over me but i
didn't go to i didn't go
to my cousin joe's brunch because of
that i i stayed there i was furious
how old was how old were you i was 13 so
let's reverse engineer she was probably
in her late 30s
that's a tough look yeah hey where you
going
who's the war paid for honey let's go
put your hair down let's get yeah yeah
you got one guy to impress and his
name's tucker t
and he's right there with chili on his
shirt
so go put on a pair of [ __ ] slacks
and let's go
before i miss it on the page he can't
even spell harley davidson all right
oh that's good oh man that's a [ __ ]
home rin um
all right this is from chelsea renee uh
have you ever dipped your finger in
dipping sauce after you ran out of fries
eggman looking at you on this one
well um let's say
the last of whatever it was
my fingers definitely got mixed in there
to get as much
as i possibly could out of it i wouldn't
say raw fingers
what are we talking like caramel or
chocolate or something here dip my head
in there what are you talking about
i don't know no not not straight fingers
ketchup
not straight fingers never like a pinky
like a little dab will do you like
you're testing a bag of a bag of hooch
no but i would do that with peanut
butter or like nutella or jelly
margarine yeah i used to eat jelly i
don't know maple syrup
mayo mr what i used to just eat jelly
gotta get those [ __ ] three to six
servings of fruit in somehow
smuckers it's got to be good what's your
preferred dip
i'm sorry you're if you had to like rate
your your go-to
condiment dip what would it be like
we're talking about dips at like a super
bowl party
no like proper dips like bean dip salad
dip
buffalo chicken if we're in that world
buffalo chicken dip is the criteria i
was thinking more i was thinking more
like honey mustard
sauce you're talking about sauce sauce
speak english all right
saint chicago same [ __ ] what kind of
uh
down there at mahoney's in chicago what
kind of boomer sauce do you
put on your fries there okay you haven't
you have you guys ever order a chicken
willy sammy
[Laughter]
you have fries chicago handshake and a
dr pepper please
you have you have fries extracted you
have you have
[ __ ] ketchup on the plate you put
your fry into the ketchup what are you
calling that motion
it's a dip dip you damn it but you dip
it in the sauce yeah that would be a
sauce barbecue sauce
dipped to me it's not ketchup sauce it's
not honey mustard sauce
yes it is i think it's honey mustard
sauce yeah there's honey mustard sauce
there's sauces i think you might i see
where you're going you had me be dead to
rights on the ketchup sauce
but it's not mayonnaise i think it's
even condiments it's even ketchup sauce
a dip is a spinach chip artichoke
artichoke dip
[ __ ] buffalo chicken dead all right
fine what's your go-to
sauce uh great question
tomato moving on
i would i would have to say um as a
portly gentleman
i always come back to the honey mustard
never did it for me oh pick a lane will
you does it for me it's the best
dipping cape cod kettle cooked chips
straight in a honey mustard with a ham
and cheese sandwich on rye with a little
mayo and swiss
dude a good night mustard and i'd rather
[ __ ] eat axle grease get out of here
with that stuff
that can be arranged i got a semi-truck
outside patreon.com my dad drives drunk
um yeah i'm a you got to go cat barb
i mean barbecue's great you know a
couple of chicky tenders
there's never a big big barbecue guy big
ranch guy hidden valley this we know
blue cheese i love it
i get marie's marie's chunky or i used
to
it's great um have you ever this is from
gary
gary i gotta go to geary's
gary we love you buddy have you ever
worn
sneakers to a wedding come on
i haven't but you were you wore them to
a funeral
not and sweatpants not too long ago
i wore a pair of slip-on
black veins
two and a set of daisy dukes
show off the games milkshake brings the
boys in a yard
um yeah that's true
that's tough i think i don't know laces
and so much worse and black black uh
what are they called jumpers joggers
joggers black joggers a black black un
unbuttoned button down and a and a black
um
i wouldn't say trash thing because i
think if you were
physically attractive i think if you
were it was easier to have
clothes in your size you would have okay
you would have
formal attire i think it's safe to say
you would have a pair of khakis
dress shoes and a button-up shirt you
could put on sure
yeah that's what i would think if i had
the case that dxl is expensive
[ __ ] break it break it down over
there
because they know you need it i know
otherwise you weren't in a two-way so
sadly
we were doing they got you dead to
rights put sandwiches out and [ __ ] they
know what they're doing
we were doing something not too long ago
and they always have some hot girl that
works in there
that like and some guy that's like kind
of fat but not fat but like a good
looking like
uh you know like a kevin james like a
plus size model to like make you feel
you know to be like a little competition
you put that tag team of a hot chick and
him in there and he's wearing all the
nice clothes from the store
you're fighting to get him off the
shelves
hello he's jealous of a guy who's like
285
he's like he's a [ __ ] quadruple
exposing and they got brad pitch ropes
and around here
skinny minnie over here huh uh
jesus christ um
this is from jan uh have you ever uh
wiped your ass with something other than
toilet paper [ __ ] yeah i'm a big fan of
[ __ ] paper towels
three you prefer to the point that i
have an idea
to launch a no i guess i shouldn't say
it
you i can guarantee you're never gonna
follow through with it announce it
you know they will get the seed money
man tissues
man toilet paper they have them oh they
do charlie's
one-time wet wipes or butt wipes damn
charlie one time charlie's and also dude
wipes
dude wipes oh we do ours cheaper why
don't you go back to the drawing board
on that one
just your hand it's just a glove
i've been handed up to the point where
i've used the uh cardboard
from the roll oh my god i got nothing
else but the move is you take off the
sock hand in the sock
no all the way down throw the sock out
have a good night no the move is in a
public bathroom oh okay i was obviously
the move is dump and jump
jump jump in the shower oh yeah no i'm
saying you're headed up you got nothing
going on
and you need your socks for later on
dump and jump is the official move of
2020 for age foldy
that's what i do when i want to feel
fresh i'm getting the shower
sure that's great yeah i mean that's the
second time you said that
i it's more sad to me that you got a
shower after you poop i want you to lose
weight i want you to live a healthier
lifestyle i'm trying and i'm living in
health
i'm just saying what's what does weight
have to do with that i like to feel
skinny people aren't [ __ ] and then
showering right afterwards
all right toby just said he died yeah
when he's got no tp
he's calling the john wick cleanup crew
the dude
of fedora the nondescript janitorial
holy [ __ ] and killed my dog
i'm gonna get him he'll never get me
make nine movies out of it cut it print
yeah it's tough you get hemmed up
sometimes you know what am i sure we all
do
um let's see
this is from patrick
this is we've briefly touched on this
this is from patrick and the facebook
group
do you do you park in the fire lane and
i want to bring this up i wrote this
down the other day
do you park in the follow-up question do
you park in the fire lane at the store
but put your hazards on so it's okay no
never to run in
if i'm sitting there yeah never to run
in
grocery stores there's there's too many
things to get to get jammed up in there
you did it on a convenience store you
did it the other day at a gas station at
a rest stop which
you were parked in the lane like there
wasn't even a fire lane
you stopped that was a little different
that was 100 i didn't say anything
because i wanted to save it for the bug
that was different that's different no
it's not dude you were stopped at the
stop sign there was no fire lane
yeah so you were just stopped in the
lane of the cars whatever i was
pulled over to the side no you were in
the leroy plus i just had the car wash
so they didn't have to do [ __ ] there was
bird [ __ ] all over my window but it was
yellow bird [ __ ] yeah
um could have used it one time charlie
one time fully
um yeah that was wild that was like
that was a that was a trash move there's
a parking lot everywhere
you pull up there's no fire lane and
you're at the stop sign where traffic is
intersection and you left it there hey
next time take the bus bozo i will
there's less bird [ __ ] on it
not to mention the sand you left in my
car and the uh
that you're you're habitual leaving
things in my car i know i do it to piss
you off
to be honest it's working
do you ever back not like i brought my
own sand we did a show
on a beach what do you want me to do i
didn't have my flip-flops with me do you
ever back into the spot
i always thought that was trash my dad
in the winter
i got okay which is an old-school move
backs it in the driveway so he can get
out of his plow though
yeah yeah that's an old-timer's move
new money ain't doing that ah no
automatic starter goes out starts the
car wipes it all off then
comes back inside sweatpants they're all
covered in snow with the ankles i know
the deal
go upstairs chains for work all pissed
off putting it in get away position
yeah yeah in case you gotta [ __ ] hit
the bricks yeah
another douche first couple of nights of
covet i had [ __ ] the car
on launch one oh i was the same way
ready to rocket filled the tank
it was right out front i was good that i
could get us
out of the city if the city was
crumbling pointing at the [ __ ]
verrazano bridge yeah yeah yeah i was
right by the g
i had it all [ __ ] count if we can get
over that if it's like the town if we
can get over the bridge
blow the bridge if we can get over the
bridge to jersey i'll get us
we'll go to the poconos i'll i'll break
into a house in the poke and i'll do
something that's the only problem over
here is
you gotta you got two rivers to get over
to safety i got one baby
i got six right there i got six minutes
and i'm [ __ ]
out of this dump it makes me want to
move the jersey ah dude
i did we came you dropped me off we're
right there i'm only being caught over
here
i'm three blocks away from the bridge
zip it up
zip it out i'd rather take my my
uh chances with the zombies on the
highway that [ __ ] be jammed up in the
city
yeah uh i uh my girl with the m60
hanging out the window
you got your girl at the sunroof
tank girl um you've got headsets on
rockin and rollin
how you gotta do it in the apocalypse
after you get through best job i ever
had
um the real douche tree best job i've
ever had generation kill
no abandoned brothers no stop this was
our saying for a long time
oh fury three kings
what hey spike jones take a hike will
you yep you thought it was what three
kings
that is correct great movie did it show
that with ice cube and george clooney
yeah
get out of here i never mentioned this
but uh the movie rules
rules in the beginning of the september
i was doing one of those
one of our rooftop shows on the west
side okay spike jones sitting in the
front row with his girlfriend
more of a spike lee kind of guy but
that's just do the right thing
he got game young rosario dawson foley's
trying to slip in references so he like
gets discovered
yeah uh another wild thing that happened
to me
it happened to her you know i always
just leaned into this like
references spike jones flicks there's
one dude in a subaru in vermont
losing it he lost me but he saved it on
that i'll give him that
uh toby want a cup of coffee or
something we need him a cup of coffee me
and attitude changing fully in apple and
we'll all be [ __ ] firing over here
i got every reference i just didn't give
it to you
that's how crazy he is because
it's emotional warfare you were burning
so bad i can tell you had no confidence
in any of those statements
or that any of those movies are going to
land
i knew [ __ ] meat and potatoes pat
over here wasn't going to [ __ ] know
the nuances
of independent film meet potato pat yeah
you're a sandler movie guy we're art
house people
fart house we're in the industry i'll
give you a farth house
i thought it the other day left my car
came back about five hours later
still smells like farting paint was off
that's that's being 40 right there
stinky
like five hours came back right where we
left off like the song was still playing
we've only just begun all right let's
muzzle through a couple more of these
here
um these are [ __ ] great thank you so
much
then we gotta get out of here then we
gotta get out of here we got snow
coming we're about to get dumped in we
got snow coming
well whatever you're doing you better be
inside you're going to get a foot of
snow
and the wind is what's going to be bad
did you hit your mom i love you for the
listener
she calls him and gives them all these
warnings he hangs up because i gotta
tell kippy all these things
all right so i just get like all this
anxiety
the first five minutes i get the death
report who's got what they're closing
the bridge did you hear that
kippy you gotta get home well whatever
that de blasio
and cuomo are doing dude but they're
shutting down the city again
that's what yeah yeah i got i got word
on good authority they're shutting the
city down like
what do you want me to do get my gun and
go like go to the mattresses
they close it down and close it down i'm
screwed yeah keys of the city you're a
charming guy
keys to the city they still do that
that'd be nice
it's more like a garage code i think
you're looking at me for help after you
have to dry on those spike jones
references you [ __ ]
he's dumb and mean
he's he'll be mean to it he'll be mean
to you forget he was mean to you two
minutes later and look to your friend
say a couple more
he's going to text me later man toby
with those references huh what's that
guys
that's not true yeah we're having fun
you go too far too real because you know
it's true because it might happen
yeah it's too real never
okay all right okay what was the last
question i forget we're having fun it
doesn't matter
[Music]
maybe um
this is from patrick uh have you ever
worn clothing with profana with profane
language on it in public
just like the dick johnson shirts or
whatever they are big johnson yeah
i wasn't i meant which those he had to
sneak and put on
kind of like wear a sweatshirt outside
and take it off yeah i've mentioned my
set make seven up yours t-shirt that uh
almost got me why was that bad i said up
yours remember
make seven and then up yours on the back
oh you wild
oh man they sent me to the nurse's
office and try to make me put a
sweatshirt on from the lost and found
none finished the nurses office yeah
real tight ship over there that's what
happened if you like [ __ ] your pants or
whatever they send you down there for a
new set
of drawers where you get likes yeah yeah
had it twice did you yeah we talked
about this i didn't know that
yes we had we talked about this on this
podcast this year [ __ ] seven i've had
lice
say you're over it still can't use a
comb
um uh do you put your grocery cart back
in the corral
now as a long term
uh
albertson's incorporation shout out to
the deli counter at any acme
yeah they can get a half a pound of
blazing buffalo chicken or an eight ball
whatever you need buddy if you're in the
philadelphia area
do yourself a favor stop by enact me get
some lunch meat
boar's head or stop at the yeah what
what am i a [ __ ] deatson watson guy
got my own podcast here [ __ ] someone
beats and watson ain't terrible if
there's no boar's head
if there's do you ever do you ever get
it sometimes where i'm like who cut it's
like so thick and i'm like what's going
on here i need an artist back there i
need somewhere that crumbles to tape
layered folded gently
yeah we're filming a commercial here
let's just pretend we're doing the
commercial every time
make it nice my buddy's mom vinnie was
in a first of all shopping bag with
trash do you ever have shopping bags by
you what's that
something like [ __ ] wait is the
stores called shopping bags yeah
oh man they were always undercover i'll
wait in the car
[Laughter]
what's a lyrio they were always under
construction the lights were always
flickering i was like going dude was it
going into a scary movie it was bad
but there was one in my hometown that we
never even
it was like the parking lot was hard to
get into everything else in the shopping
center was closed
it was tough it was only that in a
philly soft pretzel
factory in there but we were shopping
bags the floors were always never done
like you know what i mean like the wanna
aisle was just concrete floor and then
tiles the next it was a [ __ ] wonky
set
buffer those floors every night at good
grocery stores i know i've used to work
that machine
now they have a robot going around and
doing it yeah at the giant maybe get
your job doing that
work inside the robot excuse me
that robot just farted again
this robot won't stop eating lunch meat
insert turkey here please insert turkey
here please
why why don't they make robots that
smoke cigarettes
tobes where are you at over here we're
killing over here
speaking of kimmy can i get your uh
charger
your phone all right yeah let's wrap
this up
wrap this up gang we love you so much
this has been so much fun
i want to say this you guys are [ __ ]
hysterical it's like honestly
you kill me i [ __ ] love it i love the
[ __ ] patreon comments
i love the [ __ ] facebook group i love
the comments under the [ __ ]
uh youtube videos i sure being mean
okay everybody's genuinely worried about
work in progress here
we really appreciate it guys like i said
this is this is the last episode of the
year you're probably listening to this
in 2021 but
um you know honestly from the bottom of
our hearts this is
this you know this is [ __ ] mean so
much to us i don't want to sound like
i'm [ __ ] you know treading over
uh ground that we've already covered i
just want to express how much it means
to us you know this really is
[ __ ] career changing for us and the
support has been great thank you for
sharing with everybody thank you for
you know joining the [ __ ] patreon
thank you for listening
thank you for buying t-shirts thank you
for [ __ ] everything you guys do
it it means the [ __ ] world to us the
little pod that good baby that's right
look at us now
thank you for a fantastic year and it's
only going to get bigger in 2020 21
and we're glad that you guys are all
with us that this was the [ __ ] this
was the squad
this is it yeah i started it yeah we
love you toby love you buddy kippy love
you
thanks t-bone thanks big ma'am see you
soon